So, I think our four computer scientist can be rather optimistic
and that is also why they are all smiling a little bit here.
So, now, it's time to say goodbye to Alice, Bob, Carol, and Dave
and wish them all the best for their jobs
because in the next unit we are going to take a look at problems that are far worse
that anything you have encountered so far.
In the final unit of this course, we are going to look at problems
that are worse than NP complete problems, worse than games such as road block,
and worse than exponential time complete.
We are going to explore the very limits of computation
and look at problems that no computer can solve ever, so see you next time.